are you single and want people to think
you're in a relationship well there is
an app for that that's right there's
actually two apps for that there is
invisible boyfriend an invisible
girlfriend and basically this will fake
it for you on social media and people
will think you're in a relationship boy
what can technology do we've got a
little more info for you the app
generates believable photos of your
pretend partner by soliciting selfies
from ordinary people as opposed to using
posed looking stock images the service
is $24.99 includes a hundred texts 10
voicemails and one handwritten note they
are hoping to expand into countries
where it's a crime to be gay and people
might have an extra pressing need to
fake a heterosexual relationship so
we'll get to the gay thing in a second
but the idea that they're gonna you know
there's gonna be voicemails a
handwritten note text messages so it's
not just social media it's actually
stuff that it's beyond that like it's
like oh look you know you mean not just
I'm not just putting this stuff out
there and we're faking pictures but also
like this is intimate stuff like this is
like mom look I have text messages from
this person what has the world come to
they know we're catfishing ourselves I
mean I understand it to an extent I
think that when you see so much social
media out there of oh this is me and my
boyfriend and this is our perfect
relationship and you know and you go
home for whether it's a holiday and your
parents are asking like oh you bye don't
you have a boyfriend or you know you're
at work and other people receive flowers
there's just basically people are
looking for ways to show that they too
have it all that they're happy and this
is a way for people to do it I mean I
feel you know sad and my heart goes out
to anybody who's like lonely enough to
want to fake a relationship to show it
to other people but I also understand it
because there's so much pressure to show
everyone that you know you're involved
in these things right and having girls
sort of done this for a long time like
girls have done the thing where you
understand yourself flowers at the
office just you know oh yeah I guess
yeah we've got a couple images from the
website which we can roll through as
were as we continue to talk here
what do you make so there you go I think
so I think they're gonna have a tough
time scaling this right to keep that
same level of personalization if you're
new handwritten notes and knock it not
make it seem really inauthentic yeah
they're gonna be tough times scaling so
it may be that they get to a point this
is wishful thinking where they feel like
they have a responsibility to vet the
folks that are coming to
right for yeah right right you know but
if they did that could be an interesting
pivot to the model right we're like you
they're doing it to really fulfill a
need for the way they talked about it
someone who you know who lives in the
Bible Belt their grandparents don't want
them to know that they're gay or there's
a stalker at work or somewhere like
there-there are true use cases for it
that could be really beneficial to
society but if it became this rampant
crazy thing it was just like you know
we're getting into this weird territory
of like her and like catfishing
ourselves and like where does reality
end and I'm super into this whole
Machiavellian take two relationships I
remember I have never participated in
that but when I was reading through this
article I was like wow like there are
people that really do send themselves
flowers at work to make it look like
they're you know more desirable or
there's people that would have somebody
maybe text them or call them while
they're on a date with someone else to
make it look like they have all these
other suitors like why did I never think
of that I'm like I'm super into this now
I'm gonna be googling the like
office manipulative stuff psychological
repercussions yeah right it just seems
like a lot of work like the person
that's sending themselves flowers or
even dealing with this stuff and you get
the handwritten note like then you're
showing it to people that work than it
used to be because they do it all for
you now right it's right outsourcing it
you're outsourcing your own weird
narcissistic sad lonely you don't need
to show people that you have somebody
else but I then I feel sad say next I
know there's people watching this that
are thinking well this could be a good
idea for me and I don't even want to
judge those people because maybe it is a
good idea for you to use this right and
actually you gave a couple good examples
of why it could be good and of course
the gay thing especially in countries
where it's not legal or you could get in
some sort of trouble by having a fake
front while you actually live your life
on the side I suppose it's fine but I
was thinking this could be good for Jan
Brady because remember Jan Brady never
had a boyfriend and then she invented
George class yes that's what I'm saying
I'm super into this whole inventing some
one thing in just the psychology behind
it and what I understand is that we're
doing the extreme examples we were
talking about how if you live in the
Bible Belt and your family you know is
concerned that you're gay and you want
to prove that you're not which also
opens up a whole nother can of worms if
should you stand by you you are or
should you invent somebody just satisfy
you're right you're doubling down on the
the second leg exactly and then what we
were getting into what they say that
they're one of their end games is is
creating profiles for people that are in
countries where maybe you could actually
be thrown off of the top of something
for being gay I mean this could be a
really helpful tool for people at the
same time but right now it just sounds
like entertaining and fun I thought when
we make up a fake boyfriend right now on
the side all right if you want to be a
real boyfriend for Jen Hoffman comment
right down below Molly you've got a
boyfriend right - so yeah she doesn't
need this app sorry